everyone welcome to this live session of
your daily equation I always look
forward to these Friday sessions I have
to tell you it's my favorite thing to
interact live spontaneous as opposed to
the things that we filmed to try to get
some of these ideas out there obviously
the quality of the live is not quite as
sharp as the quality that we can get by
doing filming just before we send them
out but the live really has an energy
that I certainly enjoy so anyway let's
begin and I hope you don't get tired of
this but I always love to see if you
could just sort of chime in and let me
know where you're watching from I see
summon is there from Italy somewhere
from Staten Island and Friday of other
places scroll by which is which is fine
and then please feel free to to send in
Germany as well send in a turkey in
London and so if I send in any questions
that you have as I would love to get to
as many of them as I can all right so
let me begin with as the the countries
cities scroll by let me begin with a
question that we have from YouTube and
then I'll go to the live chat that is
scrolling by as I'm talking to you right
now so let's see Andrew coming from
YouTube as pres greeting if if you see
this I was wondering if the different
interpretations of quantum physics
agreed that a particle doesn't have a
well-defined position before it is
measured and and the answer to your
question Andrew some people may find a
little bit surprising because we're so
used to quantum mechanics telling us
that you know this world is this
nebulous collection of probabilities
until an observation or an interaction
forces the world in some sense to choose
one definite outcome from the range of
possible outcomes allowed by the quantum
laws and that suggests and indeed most
physicists do have the perspective that
a particle does not have a position
until it is measured that is the
standard interpretation of what quantum
mechanics are telling us but there is an
approach to quantum mechanics that
doesn't get a whole lot of attention it
was developed by Prince Louis dubrow
back in the 1920s and also by David Bohm
the physicist who kind of rediscovered
this idea I think it was in the 1950s
and in that approach to quantum
mechanics which makes the same
predictions a standard quantum mechanics
it just is a different slightly
different mathematical formalism there's
an additional equation beyond
Schrodinger's equation and maybe I
should do that one of these your daily
equation episodes just to show that
equation but in this approach particles
actually do have definite positions
before they are measured
there is no measurement problem in the
Dubrow Bohm approach to quantum
mechanics there are other weirdnesses to
this approach there is the capacity
right in the equations to do something
over here and to immediately influence
some
over there not just through a quantum
entanglement which is weird enough and
that's in standard quantum mechanics
this is a more in-your-face nonlocality
doing something here effects something
over there and I think that's why many
people don't take the approach as
seriously as they might but to answer
your question Andrew yeah there is a
different interpretation of quantum
mechanics which particles do have
definite positions so that is not a
universal quality of all approaches to
quantum mechanics all right let's see
what we have here Don Francisco asks how
is it that time can be different for
people in space compared to earth I have
never understood this and Don yeah the
you wouldn't understand that if you
didn't study say the general theory of
relativity if you base your
understanding of the world as most of us
do except the weird group of physicists
who sort of spend their lives
investigating the universe in the
language of mathematics that shows us
that observations can be misleading but
if most of us base our understanding of
the world
from experience from observations then
yeah we would come to the conclusion
that time elapsed is the same for you
and me and everybody else regardless of
what they're doing how fast they're
moving where they might be none of that
would affect the Newtonian the classical
notion of time but what Einstein taught
us is that when you think deeply about
the force of gravity you realize that
gravity is tightly connected to the
curvature of space in fact more
precisely and more relevant to your
question
gravity is associated to the curvature
of space and time now
curved space is something that we at
least can picture you've seen those
images I use them all the time where
you've got the Sun and space kind of
warps around it so you have some
intuition about what physicists mean
when they talk about warps in space
curves in space
what do physicists mean what does
Einstein a particular mean when he talks
about
curvature of time warping time what that
means is clocks located at different
positions in a gravitational field will
tick off time at different rates
this emerges from Einstein's equations
of the general theory of relativity
nobody expected this nobody thought that
this would be true nobody would have
even considered this idea until it
popped out of the equations in fact one
way of interpreting what Einstein found
is this when you drop an object we all
know it falls downward it falls toward
the earth according to Einstein's math
what's really going on here the object
is trying to move in a direction in
which time elapses more slowly time does
elapsed more slowly on the earth
compared to a clock that's ever higher
up ever further from the source of
gravity
it's as if gravity pulls on time slowing
its passage and this is such a crazy
idea that nobody really would believe it
until it was experimentally verified and
it was verified I don't remember the
exact year but I believe the first
experiment took place at Harvard there's
a there's a shaft as I understand it I
went to Harvard but I probably should
have looked at the shaft that probably
didn't know about this experiment at the
time but there's a shaft I think in one
of the physics buildings at Harvard and
scientists use that shaft to shine light
up and down the shaft and light can be
thought of as a clock because light is a
wave that oscillates and the oscillation
of the light is like a tick tock tick
tock tick tock tick tock so they were
able to measure the tick tocks
of light the frequency of the light as
it went up and down the shaft as it went
further from the center of the earth
closer to the center of the earth
further from the center of the earth may
found that indeed the clock slowed down
the closer it was to the surface of the
earth and it sped up relatively speaking
the farther it was from the center of
the earth so this is how time works and
hope that gives you some insight as to
where the
idea comes from but yeah dab this in
your intuition pretty tough absolutely
pretty tough okay other questions
that'll take from the live feed if I can
find one oh why do some mr. castle DK
asks why do some amounts of energy
manifest as particles while others do
not and and that's that's it that's a
good question and it's a question that
we can answer with a body of physical
understanding called quantum field
theory quantum field theory is the
blending of quantum mechanics with the
fields that we believe permeate the
universe the electromagnetic field the
gravitational field the nuclear fields
the particle fields and so forth and
within that equations of quantum field
theory you see that energy can manifest
itself as excitations of these various
fields and when the energy is deposited
in say a single the smallest possible
excitation of a field that is what we
mean by a particle an electron is the
smallest possible excitation of the
electron field the photon is the
smallest possible excitation of the
electromagnetic field now when you have
a huge number of these excitations a
huge number of photons in some sense
they can fill out a wave and now the
wave-like description of energy comes to
the fore but when you're talking about
excitations that are discrete as opposed
to a huge number of excitations all
blended together into an oscillating
wave when you have a discrete say
singular excitation and that's what we
mean by a particle and the ebb and flow
of energy between these various ways
that fields can be excited is determined
by the mathematics of quantum field
theory so in the end that mathematical
equation or set of equations
is the ultimate answer to your question
but intuitively energy can a band flow
between these various kinds of
excitations all right professor Greene
Corey O'Connell asks can you explain how
the mathematics within string theory
combines both relativity and quantum
mechanics and yeah sort of so that's a
that's a big question that's a question
that would take you know many episodes
of the more pedagogical versions of your
daily equations that we do every day or
almost every day some of you may have
noticed that I missed one day yesterday
was the first day I missed in 17 days so
I hope that's okay
it became a little bit difficult due to
various issues to get that episode out
but we'll pick it up with those on
Monday but to the question of how string
theory puts gravity and quantum
mechanics together general relativity
quantum hands together let me give you a
quick explanation so why is there a
problem to put gravity and quantum
mechanics together there's a problem
because quantum mechanics describes the
world in terms of the quantum mechanical
uncertainty principle which will be next
Monday's your daily equation so you may
know the ideas already but roughly
speaking the uncertainty principle says
the universe is always jittery
fluctuating uncertain and that
uncertainty manifests itself larger and
larger and smaller and smaller scales
and when you apply that uncertainty to
the fabric of space itself it means that
Einstein's vision of space as a gently
curving geometrical object that picture
doesn't work when you go into the
microscopic realm because space itself
is undulating so ferociously that it
rips apart it comes back together pieces
tear off and those quantum processes
applied to the fabric of space prevent
the math of quantum mechanics and
general relativity from blending
together harmoniously
what does string theory do string theory
says look if your fundamental entity in
the world is not a dot of no size but
rather a loop a string of a particular
small but finite size
you can never probe smaller than that
finite size and indeed when you look at
that in detail you find that the problem
in putting gravity and quantum mechanics
together only really emerged on scales
smaller than a string but string theory
basically says there are no such scales
you can't probe any smaller than the
smallest ingredient in the theory and
roughly speaking that's how string
theory triumphs puts gravity and quantum
mechanics together like placing a cutoff
on the small distance scales in the
universe there by cutting out the
potential incompatibility quantum
mechanics and general relativity that's
the basic idea all right
what do we have here Vivek toed Aria
asks sir and I like that thank you for
calling me sir so polite appreciate that
see if I get my kids to call me sir
I like that sir can we know the center
of the universe there must be a place
where the Big Bang occurred and and
Vivek I I totally understand where
you're coming from if you think about
the Big Bang as an explosion an event in
a pre-existing world a pre-existing
universe then your intuition would be
spot-on that explosion would have
happened someplace in space and it'd be
interesting to figure out where that
location was but the modern view of
cosmology suggests strongly that that's
not the right way of thinking about what
the Big Bang actually was the Big Bang
was not an explosion in a pre-existing
spatial expanse at was already there the
Big Bang is the process by which space
and time themselves came into existence
so the Big Bang therefore can really be
thought of as taking place where you are
now sitting where I am now sitting where
that tree to my right is where this
coffee cup is sitting because all these
distinct locations throughout all of
space
they were the same location in the early
moments of the universe because space
itself in the form that we witnessed did
not exist only through the expansion of
the Big Bang did we get space that we
are familiar with so an answer to your
question of where the Big Bang occurred
I would say everywhere because
everywhere that we have access to was
the same where was the same location at
the moment of the Big Bang
Lala Zumba asks hi professor Greene can
a black hole
emit particles other than photons via
Hawking radiation and the question and
and you're absolutely right 1974 Stephen
Hawking shocked the world of physics by
establishing that black holes that we
had long thought to be entities that
only draw material in there black after
all nothing comes out of a black hole
Hawking show that when you take quantum
mechanics into account that is not
correct quantum mechanics allows a
certain amount of radiation to leak
through the surface of a black hole and
often when we talk about that radiation
we do frame it in terms of photons and
lava is asking well okay photons can get
out can other kinds of particles get out
too and the answer is absolutely yes
the only special thing about photons is
because they've got zero rest mass it's
somewhat easier if you will for them to
emerge from the quantum processes taking
place at the edge of a black hole to
yield heavier particles you need more
energetic processes and those more
energetic processes or rarer but in
principle any kind of particle can be
produced so long as its mass is less
than the mass of the black hole you
still can't violate energy conservation
but so long as the particle has a mass
that's less than that of the black hole
in principle it can
yield radiation of that particle through
these quantum processes alright
continuing onward
let's see gosh I kind of keep to some
scrolling so fast I had a good one and
then it slipped away
okay Scott Wilson asked how can
something with zero mass move because no
mass equals no energy what Scott has in
mind there I presume is that Einsteins e
equals MC squared tells us that energy
and mass are related in by in that in
that simple mathematical formalism which
means that if n 0 then e equals 0 times
e squared so we should be zero so how in
the world can a particle move if it has
zero mass it has therefore zero energy
in the answer to that question is well I
should note that the answer to that
question is covered in your daily
equation even as an admonition I mean
that if you want to look further into
the ideas that I'm talking about go back
to not episode one of your daily
equation where I did equals MC squared
but there's a later episode and I wish I
could remember which one it was but in
one of those later episodes I did
address this question but here's the
answer to your question
each equals MC squared is actually a
shorthand
shorthand in two ways number one as
written it only applies to particles
that have nonzero rest mass moreover the
real way to write that equation is e
equals M 0 C squared times 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared there's a factor of gamma that
comes into the real form of equals MC
squared where you see energy in the
sense of the rest mass of a particle
plus the kinetic energy of motion the
velocity comes into the story there but
all of that derivation is really only
true for a particle that has nonzero
rest mass for a particle with 0 rest
mass we have a different formula it's a
formula that emerged initially from the
work of Max Planck and Einstein himself
in 1905 with the photoelectric effect
which is episode 8 of your daily
equation we've covered a lot of these
key ideas and in that formula we have
not equals mc-squared but e equals H nu
H is Planck's constant and nu is the
frequency of vibration which when you
apply that to a photon that has zero
rest mass the photon is a particle of
light there is frequency associated with
that light and therefore the energy can
be thought of as being embodied in the
frequency in the color as opposed to the
mass and that's why photon can have
energy and ye can move even though its
rest mass to zero you cannot apply
equals mc-squared
in the case of zero rest mass okay dr.
green
someone just that was a good one john
pro-rata dis John Pavano dis says dr.
green what are your favorite subjects to
teach undergraduates and John if you ask
me that question a few years ago I would
have said I love teaching quantum
mechanics
I love teaching general relativity I
love teaching a course that I made up
called geometry and physics where I put
the mathematical methods of geometry
together with physics and teach all
sorts of cool stuff there and that's
what I did for 30 years and I still
teach those subjects but I have to say
that my favorite thing to teach now and
I don't mean this as an advertisement I
just did a live session in the hour
before the
with reddit in which I was talking about
this thing over here this is my book
your until the end of time and I teach a
course based upon this book and I have
to tell you that has been the most
gratifying teaching experience of my
life and the reason I say that is you
know when you teach a course in quantum
mechanics and when we talk about quantum
mechanics here you know it can blow your
mind a little bit it's strange it's
weird it gives you insight into the
nature of reality and I'd love that and
many students love that and I hope that
you all love that but when I teach this
book which is trying to see where we
human beings fit within these ideas and
and how we can find meaning and purpose
in a world governed by quantum mechanics
and general relativity mathematical laws
that seem not to care about us one whit
teaching a course of that sort you can
reach students in a different way I
teach them about quantum mechanics and
general relativity in the course but I
also teach them to try to grasp how the
human species fits within the
cosmological unfolding from the Big Bang
until the end of time and it's a much
more emotional it's a much more visceral
experience than teaching quantum
mechanics and general relativity and
that's why I have found it so gratifying
over the last couple of years so if any
of you are going to be enrolled in
Columbia in the fall Columbia University
is where I teach I'm teaching this
course it is filled up already but if
any of you want to get into that course
and excuse me I'm gonna have a tea leaf
in my mouth a little gross sorry about
that
um you should check it out because it's
a course that allows you to think about
scientific ideas in a different way all
right let me scroll down here and see
what else we got here what does oh god
the stops : omnia I'm trying to hold
this and it keeps going by too fast I
don't know I can't hold it in place
hello sir another's here I love that how
far are we successful in understanding
dark energy I sit - asks and I would say
we are very successful in understanding
the implications of dark energy
the expansion of the universe so we
understand that dark energy yields a
repulsive gravitational push and it can
explain the accelerated expansion of
space that was discovered in the end of
the 1990s so that's that's great but if
you ask me do I really know what dark
energy fundamentally is and what its
fundamental properties actually are are
we confident that it has the equation of
state that we use to explain the
accelerated expansion of space I don't
so there's a lot of observational
astronomy that needs to be undertaken
now and in the near future which I hope
will get us to that deep understanding
that we as yet do not have okay so Mike
R asks who creates our builder and I
guess what mike means by builder is the
Creator right the creator of the
universe that some people imagine is out
there and I kind of had this discussion
an hour ago on reddit so I won't go into
great detail but I'd simply say Mike
your question is the key one because if
you imagine that there was a creator
that created this universe and that is
the answer to why there's a universe at
all you're still left with the question
who created the Creator which is a
question in my mind that's on par with
why is there something rather than
nothing too deep question of physics
you're just substituting one word
creator for the previous word universe
if you will so I don't think a creator
gets you very far at least in a
satisfying way to the Beeb answers for
exactly the question that Mike R asks
who built the builder who created the
Creator so here we have a question from
no one that's a nice nice name professor
could you record your lectures from
Columbia University and release it on
YouTube that's an interesting idea I
have done that for some of my lectures I
didn't really do it on YouTube but we
have this website you know this is a an
event from the world science festival
which is an organization that I
co-founded with the producer Tracy day
some years ago and within the world
science festival we have something old
world science you
so it's it's gonna be relaunched in
about a week or two so if you're
interested you can find a whole course
that I did I'm the special theory of
relativity
it's got hundreds of animations that
were created by our wonderful team
including one individual who is
producing this program right now Josh
Zimmerman created these wonderful
graphics that are in the special theory
of relativity course so you should go
check that out I don't think it's
available right now but I think maybe
April 29th is the relaunch of world
signs use so keep your eyes open and
there's there are two courses they're
from Columbia that I teach at Columbia
that you can take for free online at
world science U so bhavya Shah asks how
far can we go into the multiverse theory
and look here's my view on on the
possibility of a multiverse it is an
idea that naturally emerges from the
equations of cosmology there is a theory
called inflationary cosmology developed
by some of the Great's of our age Alan
Guth Andrei Linde a Paul Steinhardt
Andres Albrecht many people have
developed these ideas in the decades
since it was first proposed back in the
1980s and in that theory it turns out
that it's very natural for our Big Bang
to not be the only Big Bang it's very
natural in the mathematics for our Big
Bang to be one of a collection of big
bangs maybe an infinite collection of
big bangs which would yield an infinite
number of universes and that would
constitute one version of the multiverse
do I believe this idea look it's a
natural consequence of equations that
are really good at describing things
that we do observe in the world like the
cosmic microwave background radiation so
these ideas are worthy of our attention
but I think it would be too strong for
me to say that I believe in the
multiverse I believe it's an idea worthy
of attention but I only believe things
that have observational or experimental
support and as yet the multiverse
doesn't have that support
so I allow it as a possibility but I
would say it's too
strong to describe it as a belief or
confidence in the idea of a multiverse
okay so I'm now scrolling through and
Rob Vandenberg Rob Vandenberg hmm we
used to have a neighbor here called Jim
Vandenberg I wonder if they are related
if I would move towards a clock at or
near the speed of light I would see the
clock running faster because of the
Doppler effect and Rob you're absolutely
correct when you talk about reality from
the standpoint of physics and in
particular special theory of relativity
you need to distinguish between two
things you need to distinguish between
your perception of reality the things
that you would see versus the objective
qualities of the world responsible for
creating the conditions that yield the
light that allows you to see what's
happening in the world and it is the
case that when you say run toward a
clock that clocks in motion from your
perspective which means according to the
special theory of relativity that clock
is ticking slow from your perspective
that's the objective reality but the
light that that clock is giving off as
you note because you're getting closer
and closer to the clock the light has to
travel less and less distance to reach
your eyeball I mean you take that into
account your perception your observation
would attribute that the clock is
ticking faster but if you then unwind
your observation to figure out what's
happening to the clock for it to appear
to be doing what it's doing you realize
that the clock has to be taking off
slower in order that the rate of speed
up that you see matches your observation
matches the equation so yes you see the
clock as though it's ticking faster but
the reality
behind-the-scenes so to speak is that
it's ticking slower important
distinction and if you'd like in that
special relativity course that I
mentioned at world signs you that may be
available now but certainly by April
29th it will be available there's a
whole module on distinguishing between
distinguishing between what I call
observation and measurement observation
is your question what you see in the
world measurement is what you deduce
about the world based on your
observations and those need not be the
same I mean anybody who's gone to a
baseball game right you know that if you
got the cheap seats you're in the
outfield bleachers when you know when
Erin judge hits that baseball you see
the ball fly off the bat before you hear
it that observation might lead you to
think that the ball leaving the bat and
the sound created by the batter two
different events because you see them
you hear them at two different moments
but of course you know that your
observation is misleading you need to
unwind it to figure out the actual
reality of what created the stimulus
that you're seeing in your hearing and
of course when you unwind it you realize
that the bat hit the ball and simply
that the sound waves take longer time to
reach your ears and that's why your
observations suggest that these two
events are different when the reality
behind the scenes is that they are the
same you have to distinguish between
observation and measurement all right
Fareed Cedeno as what are some of the
dimensions predicted by string theory
well string theory requires that there
are more dimensions of space than the
three dimensions that we know about
right you look around the world what do
you see thank you look at an object all
right my book right what does it have
it's got length
it's got width and it's also got height
right three dimensions of everyday
experience and that's the case of
everyday objects but string theory
suggests that in addition to length and
height in addition to left-right
back-forth and up-down there are more
dimensions of space and in a way those
dimensions are not particularly exotic
they're just like these dimensions of
space there
much smaller we believe curled up into
tiny shapes so small that we do not see
them but other than that space is kind
of space it's just more of them than we
thought based on everyday experience
alright what do we have here
professor what according to you is the
future of science what can we expect to
see in our lifetime asks obby I'm so
sorry
beach if nog I'm sorry I'm so bad at
being able to pronounce names that are
unfamiliar to me but that's a very good
question what can we expect to see in
our lifetime let me say my dream my
dream is that we will gain insight into
the true nature of space and time we
know a lot about space from Einstein
warps and curves right it can ripple
gravitational waves very recently that
idea has been confirmed through
observation we know a lot about time we
know how it ticks off we know how it
takes off a different race depending
upon motion and gravity some of which we
discussed here today but if you ask me
what space is and what time is nobody
can really give the answer to that yet
our space and time built up of smaller
ingredients like molecules and atoms of
space and time there's a suggestion in
string theory that that idea might be
true and I would hope that in our
lifetime to answer the question that
maybe we will get to a point where we're
able to answer that question that to me
would be the big dream the other big
dream to just go to a different subject
is if we could gain an understanding of
what consciousness is I don't mean like
sort of woowoo consciousness I'm talking
about the fact that you and I both have
these inner worlds of conscious
experience where does that come from how
can it be the particles come together to
yield the inner world of human
reflection that is an idea that I spent
a lot of time in this book investigating
but there are insights into it but the
the jury is still out that would be
another big insight that I would imagine
or hope that we could one day get to
okay what do we have here
let's see so I was just about to do
Krishna's question it went by come on
stop moving on me ere Ernest asks the
space/time have mass because it can
curve so I believe it should have mass
and that that is a subtle question and
the answer is sort of yes right so what
I mean by that is in Einstein's
equations any energy regardless of the
source will have an impact on the
curvature of space time and gravity
itself which is the curvature of
space-time can have energy right
I mean gravitational waves are ripples
through the fabric of space-time they
have energy they can make a detector
stretch and shrink that's how we observe
them and therefore gravity itself can
contribute to graffity gravity itself
can contribute the energy in the
gravitational field can contribute to
the warping of space-time so in that
sense the answer is absolutely yes okay
sheet al Angra asked professor of the
Big Bang created equal amounts of matter
and antimatter why don't we see a
antimatter around in the universe today
in fact you could even ask that question
a slightly different way sheet tau which
is if there was an equal amount of
matter and antimatter in the early
universe by now wouldn't of the matter
found the antimatter and annihilated
into energy so there'd be no matter or
antimatter left that is a puzzle we
believe the answer to that puzzle is
that ultimately in the unfolding of the
cosmos an imbalance between matter and
antimatter emerged and we have an
understanding of the conditions
necessary for that in bounds to take
place
it requires that certain symmetries
called charleen generation symmetry and
parity symmetry need to be violated and
we believe we understand in principle
ways in which those symmetries could
have been violated and with that
together with the expanding universe you
can arrive at a situation in which there
could be slightly more matter than
antimatter
slightly more matter than antimatter
which means imagine that you have a
billion and one particles of matter for
every billion particles of antimatter
than the billion particles of matter and
billion particles of antimatter they
will annihilate into energy and one
particle of matter will be left over and
a matter happening over and over again
throughout the universe you get a little
residual matter left over in that little
residual matter may in fact be why we
are here if you're interested to explore
that idea further I should mention the
World Science Festival you know you're
all watching this World Science Festival
feed has a program that we released a
couple months ago is called the matter
of antimatter and it's a program that I
moderated I led a conversation among
some of the world experts on the very
question of matter versus antimatter and
it was kind of a fun journey through
these ideas so I suggest you check out
that program it's probably somewhere on
the very page where you're looking right
now the matter of antimatter definitely
worth ninety minutes to check that out
quail Zachary asks does light experience
time I'm sorry no I'm sorry
not that's a common as is your bed so
it's not quail I'm gonna try to get this
one right ah oh you well something like
that
anyway I love the question does light
experience time because if you look at
the time dilation of Albert Einstein
which was the second episode in your
daily equation says you go check it out
if you haven't looked at that there's a
factor called gamma which is one over
the square root of 1 minus V squared
over C squared I wonder if I could even
bring that up on the screen here and I'm
gonna risk doing that does this work I'm
gonna see let's just see this love to
use technology stuff so if I can bring
this up I will try do you see that
little scribble there I think you do
good so what we did in that episode we
found that there's this guy called gamma
which is one over the square
root of 1 minus V squared over C squared
and this factor which was the daily
equation for episode number 2 tells you
the factor by which clocks slow down
right and V is the speed of that clock
so if you notice if you let V approach
the speed of light C then gamma goes to
1 over the square root of something that
gets very very close to zero and
anything divided by 0 this is going to
infinity which means that a clock that's
traveling at the speed of light would
appear to slow down by a factor of
infinity which would seem to suggest
that a light beam experiences no time at
all and that's the origin of the
question I presume does light experience
time if you have this infinite factor of
slowed down and and so roughly speaking
I can say no photon doesn't experience
any time but but you have to take that
with a grain of salt because like a
photon is not a conscious being right
and when you're talking about the
experience of elapsed time you have in
mind your experience and you're
imagining that the photons version is
your experience slowed down by a factor
of infinity but the photon doesn't have
conscious awareness it doesn't have
experiences so the notion of time not
elapsing for the photon is a is true
poetically it's true in the limit of
mathematical equations but I wouldn't
take it too far like to think about it
as the experience of all time at once
that's kind of pressing the issue into a
place that I'd have difficulty condoning
so so poetically yes metaphorically yes
but literally you have to be very
careful ascribing the experience of to a
photon all right
then Sonny asks can we go and come back
from a black hole without any hindrance
and yeah I'm principle
in principle if you stay outside the
event horizon of a black hole right if
the black hole as a mass M then there's
a beautiful little formula that you can
work out for how big the black hole is
you take two multiply it by Newton's
constant G multiply it by the mass of
the black hole and divide through by C
squared and that number tells you how
close you can safely get to a black hole
without being pulled in and if you stay
outside that number to DM over C squared
then in principle you can go to the
black hole's edge turn around and come
back and if you do that when you come
back you will note that you come back to
the future' if you spend time near the
edge of a black hole time elapses there
more slowly so clocks back on earth will
be ticking fast while your clock is
ticking off time slow so if you spend
like a year or hanging out near the edge
of a black hole and then you come back
to earth it might be ten years in the
future or a thousand years in the future
a billion years into the future so the
journey that you're talking about may
seem to be a journey through space you
go from Earth to the black hole and then
you come back but it's actually also a
journey through time because when you go
to the black when you come back it will
not be the amount of time that you think
should have elapsed
it'll be much more on planet Earth okay
so how we doing on time yeah we got
about 10 15 minutes to go so oh where
should we take from maybe I should go
back to the YouTube and just grab one
there just to keep this evenly divided
so cat from YouTube says hello I'm
Kaitlin from North Carolina because the
growth of the universe is accelerating
will the expansion ever catch up to the
speed of light and the answer Kaitlin is
is yes in fact even even right now if
you think about objects that are
efficiently far away their speed is
proportional to their distance from us
because the fabric of space is
stretching which means that the more
fabric there is between you and me the
faster we will recede from each other
galaxy is really far away from us then
it can rush away from us at a speed
that's greater than the speed of light
and that means that we won't be able to
see that galaxy because once something's
moving away from us faster than the
speed of light the light it emits will
fight a losing battle to reach us and
the accelerated made sure set in the far
future all of the distant galaxies the
ones that are not bound towards
gravitationally the so called local
group but all other galaxies besides the
local group they ultimately will be
moving away from us at a speed that's
greater than the speed of light so when
we look out into the universe in the far
future it's gonna be dark katelyn we
won't see anything because all those
distant galaxies will have rushed away
at a speed faster than the speed of
light we won't be able to see them at
all all right let's see here
I'm asked by Prakash whether the fabric
of space can tear and that's a question
that's kind of near and dear to my heart
because in the Einstein theory in
general theory of relativity space can't
tear in Einstein's theory space can
stretch it can deform it can warp it can
curve and so on but it can't rip apart
the space were to rip apart in
Einstein's theory the math it just kind
of falls apart the thing just crashes
and burns and a project that we started
to work on back in the 1990's goodness
gracious almost 30 years ago now a
project that I worked on with a number
of colleagues we asked ourselves the
following question basically your
question Prakash we said look if we look
at how the space evolves not in the
general theory of relativity which
ignores quantum mechanics but if we
include quantum mechanics
that string theory puts quantum
mechanics and Einstein's theory together
into a unified mathematical structure
could space tear in that setting and we
found that space can tear we found a
number of ways that the fabric of space
could rip apart and we found that when
it rips apart the theory is perfectly
well behaved the math does not blow up
in your face the theory does not crash
and burn so that doesn't prove that
space actually tears in the real world
as we don't know if string theory is a
description of the real world but at
least in the only theory that we have
that can really address this question by
putting grabbed in quantum mechanics
together we find that space can't air at
least the mathematic says that ripping a
part of space is something completely
consistent with the underlying physical
laws so thank you for that question okay
Alice asks hi Brian what is your
favorite book do you have any book
recommendations for people hoping to
study physics in university well you
know it's hard to answer that question
without sounding self-serving but you
know I really do like my latest book I
really encourage you don't have to buy
it find a fake PDF online they exist go
to the library I'm not trying to make
money on this but I think you'll find
the story that I tell in this book which
weaves together physics as well as the
concerns of a conscious self reflecting
species called human beings I think
you'll find that journeying interesting
and gratifying so that's one book that I
would suggest but in terms of other
hardcore physics books I would say that
one of my favorites is Stephen
Weinberg's
gravitation and cosmology principles and
applications of the general theory of
relativity
I bought that book on as an
undergraduate I had no idea what it was
saying it was well beyond my ability to
understand as a freshman in college but
it's one of them best written books that
explores Einsteins
ideas by true master of the subject so
from the science perspective that
certainly is a book that is worth having
on your bookshelf worth taking down from
the bookshelf and actually reading it is
masterful explication of the general
theory of relativity okay what else do
we have here do have time yeah we got
about 10 minutes or so um let me find a
good question that just fires me up okay
padishah asks what is the quantum
measurement problem yeah and you know
I've spoken about it before but it's
such a vital problem it's worth spending
another moment on it according to
quantum mechanics and this is again
something that we cover it in an earlier
episode of your daily equation I don't
remember which episode it was but in in
one of the earlier episodes maybe the
Schrodinger's equation episode it could
be I discussed where the motivation for
the quantum laws come from and in there
I described how the new paradigm of
quantum mechanics is to predict
probabilities of outcomes instead of
definite outcomes
that's the Newtonian picture is tell me
how things are today and I'll predict
how they will be tomorrow
the quantum paradigm the new paradigm is
tell me how things are today and I will
predict the probability of getting one
or another outcome in the future
now the quantum measurement problem your
question is this when you measure a
physical system you find one definite
outcome you never perform a measurement
and say well I found it here and there I
found the electron was both here and
there that never happens you find the
electron here or you find the electron
there quantum measurement question is
how does the universe progress from this
probabilistic description in which the
particle might be here here there are
some place else how do we progress from
that to the single definite outcome that
each and every measurement reveals how
does that happen mathematically and
physically we don't know the answer to
that and that's the quantum measurement
problem and one that doesn't receive as
much attention as
deserves because it doesn't affect our
ability to make predictions the
probabilistic predictions are still
there but how do I get the math to yield
a definite outcome nobody really knows
ok what else do we have here does
gravity affect antimatter in the same
way as matter crack crack
nice name crack asks this question and
the answer is yes so matter and
antimatter particle of matter and its
anti matter cousin say the electron and
the positron one of the deep theorems of
physics is called the cpt theorem and
that basically ensures that a particle
of matter and the corresponding particle
of antimatter have the same mass and
mass is the thing that gravity responds
to mass and energy are the things that
gravity responds to as well as momentum
in the general theory of relativity so
since the particle and the antiparticle
from the standpoint of their fundamental
rest mass have the same features then
gravity treats them in the same manner
[Music]
next Nexus motion as can you please
share how exactly the universe is finely
tuned for life and yeah you know when we
look out at the world and carefully
measure it and examine it we find that
there are certain fundamental numbers
that seem to be inherent to reality
numbers like the mass of the electron
the mass of the quarks the strength of
gravity the strength of the
electromagnetic force the strength of
the nuclear forces on and on and on a
list of about 2024 numbers that we have
measured with great precision nobody has
any understanding of why those numbers
have the particular values that they do
nobody knows why the electron has its
particular mass for example now you
might wonder if we should care about
explaining the values of those numbers
maybe we should just accept
them as a quality of the world that's it
now the reason why we we puzzle over an
explanation for those numbers is because
we have found that if we adjust some of
those numbers many of those numbers by
even a few percent the universe as we
know it would go away
stars are the ubiquitous feature of the
cosmos stars that give rise to the heat
and light that bathe a planet like the
earth and allows life to exist stars
would not light up if you're to change
the electrons mass or its charge or the
strength of the electromagnetic force
you fiddle with those numbers stars
don't light up without stars there isn't
any life so that's the sense in which
the universe seems to be finely tuned
for light those new numbers those
numerical values seem to have been set
to just the right thighs to allow stars
to shine planets to form and at least
one such planet light to exist now
that's an interesting puzzle one
solution could be that we maybe live in
this idea that we discussed earlier
maybe live in a multiverse maybe there
are many many many many universes and
the values of those numbers vary wildly
across all of the universes and we
simply live in that universe where the
values just happen to be the ones that
we measure allowing for the processes
that allowed life to exist so maybe we
exist here and not another universe for
the same reason why we are on planet
earth and not living our lives out on
Neptune this planet is hospitable for
life when Neptune doesn't seem so maybe
similarly we live in this universe and
not another because this one happens to
be hospitable for our form of life that
could be the answer or maybe there's a
deeper explanation embedded within the
mathematical laws of physics that we
have yet to figure out all right so a
couple more questions before we wrap
this up
okay okay again a sort of similar
question from Reath ik to the time
question happened earlier since there
was infinite length contraction does
space or the universe exist for photons
so that gamma factor that I brought up
earlier that gave us that infinite time
dilation gamma equals one over the
square root of one minus V squared over
C squared V approaches C gamma goes to
infinity that an infinite factor also
suggests that the universe would crush
down in its length to zero size from the
perspective of a photon and my answer is
basically the same poetically short it's
as if the photon experiences all of say
space along the direction of its motion
simultaneously because it's all one
location it's all squeezed down but it's
only poetically it's only metaphorically
taking the perspective of a photon is a
perspective that you and I and no
sentient being will ever have we will
never travel at the speed of light we
are massive objects we are constrained
to travel at a speed less than the speed
of light so taking the perspective of a
photon is a poetic perspective but it's
not a perspective that any of us will
ever have and that's what I mean I have
to take it with a grain of salt okay
what else what else
let me find maybe something over here
Emily Emily asks why must the speed of
light be constant and Emily
I don't know there are theories in fact
and investigate the possibility that
speed of light is not constant that the
speed of light may have changed over the
course of cosmological history
I can imagine moreover a universe not
our universe apparently but a different
universe a potential universe maybe it's
not real but I can imagine the logical
possibility of a universe in which the
speed of light is not constant so the
best answer that I think science can
give to your question Emily is that the
speed of light being constant is a weird
idea
it is a counterintuitive idea but it is
an idea that allows us to explain
observations and experiments when you
assume that the speed of light is
constant all of a sudden many puzzles
completely fall into place and that
gives us confidence that this weird idea
is actually true it doesn't necessarily
mean that the idea is logically required
to be true you can imagine a reality
perhaps where it's not true but in this
reality apparently it is true so we take
it as a given and we go from there and
we draw all sorts of conclusions based
upon the constant nature of the speed of
light and each and every one of those
conclusions is borne out by observations
and that allows our confidence in the
constant nature of the speed of light to
grow and then we come to this conclusion
that it is constant but other than that
there's not much further I think at this
point of understanding that we can go
all right let me see if I can find one
more to do here so ah so Sheila from
Oklahoma asks a question Sheila said
that she was on me the reddit question
and answer that I did just an hour
before this and she had a question there
that didn't get answered so she's asking
it here which is fine she's asking you a
question so if you were going
to talk about the main idea in your new
book that puts these ideas together she
listened number of them but if you put
these ideas together from physics to
human reflection what would it be and
this is actually a question shell I
don't know if you stayed around to the
end of the read I sort of did discuss
this a little bit at the end but I'm
happy to do it here in this different
context look you know I don't think that
we're going to find purpose and meaning
written into the fundamental laws of
physics I don't think that within the
equations of general relativity or
quantum mechanics or whatever the future
laws of physics that we discover maybe I
don't think you're ever gonna find a
place in which you're gonna say aha
there is the reason why we humans are
here there is the purpose of life I just
don't think that the universe is built
that way we are collections of particles
governed by those physical laws and it
just so happens that for a brief period
of time the ingredients come together to
yield conscious beings like ourselves
and conscious beings can begin to
question reality and begin to wonder
about where we came from and begin to
wonder why we are here and that's just a
natural outgrowth of the evolving nature
of complex particulate arrangements at
least some of those arrangements that
take place on planet Earth so my view is
you don't look to physics in that sense
for that kind of flat-footed
straightforward directive as to what
meaning and purpose there is in the
universe rather you look to physics to
understand the framework the context
within which living beings such as
ourselves exist and within that as I
described in the book this guy over here
within that you can find a certain kind
of gratification that we can understand
the universe and that we can question
the universe that we can create great
Wonder and great beauty I mean look at
what we've done as a species right we
built the pyramids
Beethoven writes the ninth symphony
Shakespeare Julius Caesar Macbeth
Walt Whitman Leaves of Grass I mean
coming into the modern age look at all
the the beauty and and wonder that we
can create even in lockdown have you
been watching the kind of creative
things that have been put out even just
on YouTube where we have been able to
show that even when we are challenged by
this global pandemic there still is the
creative spirit that can reach out and
create things that can touch us and to
me that's the wonder of being alive none
of this takes away sort of the pain and
tragedy of being part of a world in
which there's death destruction
pandemics that can make life so
difficult and tragic and end it for some
of us but to see that in the context of
the unfolding of the cosmos and to see
that in the context of these beautiful
laws of physics simple ideas that can
yield the complex experience of human
life to me even when we recognize that
our existence is fleeting the fact that
we exist at all is cause for celebration
it's cause for a sense of reverence and
if that's the one message that I would
say I sort of really try to talk about
this book that's actually what it would
really be alright anyway that's that's
about it for today I think I've gone
over my time a little bit by a couple
minutes come back on Monday for the next
episode of your daily equation I will -
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle and
then if you're up for it next Friday
I'll do another one of these live
sessions until then though this is Brian
Greene for your daily equation World
Science Festival also like subscribe see
that little button over there's you
subscribe to the World Science Festival
all sorts of great content if you want
you can follow me personally on Twitter
be green or Twitter or on Facebook
in any event though I will see you at
the next episode on Monday of your daily
equation until then take care